[Música]
quiero empezar solamente diciéndoles que
estar de pie en un escenario de esta
naturaleza a punto de contarles un par
de cosas que vienen desde la evidencia
más personal es algo que podrían hacer
todos y cada uno de ustedes porque
resulta que cada ser humano cada persona
tiene tanto que contar y tanto que
compartir que es igual de emocionante
así que hoy me ha tocado a mí solamente
el privilegio inmenso de poder cortar
contarles un par de pedacitos de mi
propio camino y lo que creo que
capitalizado como ser humano de esos
escenarios de esos estadios de la vida y
que espero que les puedan servir a
ustedes también
pero antes quisiera que levanten las
manos las mujeres a propósito de la
conferencia de este fin que levanten las
manos por favor solamente a las chicas
muchísimas gracias
y vamos a empezar con una dinámica para
que la parte final no sea tan cansada
[Música]
ok solamente chicas
si solamente las listas
[Música]
digamos
extinguir están cansadas chicas digamos
ah
puede ser mejor se está llegando
[Música]
no no
a
caballeros y señores
[Música]
no no
uno de los coros por favor empieza ahora
mismo
hace poco
hace poquísimos segundos hicimos un acto
de creación espontánea
y nosotros los artistas en ocasiones nos
creemos como los propietarios exclusivos
y únicos de esto que se llama
creatividad pero resulta que no es así
resulta que el acto creativo no es
patrimonio único ni potestad exclusiva
de los artistas
de hecho el término artista le cae a
todos y cada uno de los presentes cree
en eso
yo creo que si el acto creativo es una
vertiente poderosa extremadamente
poderosa que nos invade a todos desde la
elaboración de una hoja de excel desde
un powerpoint desde una canción pasando
por un reportaje
y yendo hacia la elaboración de una
defensa en términos jurídicos el acto
creativo nos invade todo el tiempo
y el acto creativo tiene algunos
enemigos tiene
algunos factores que pueden sabotear lo
bien que pueda terminar un acto creativo
hoy quiero hablarles de dos posturas en
las que fácilmente podríamos estar
identificarnos o decidir restar esas
posturas nos marcan dos caminos que son
realmente muy determinantes y siempre se
están presentando víctima o creador voy
a tratar de pararme en la mitad porque
resulta que cada día vamos escogiendo
uno de estos dos escenarios de nuestra
vida el escenario en el que ejercemos de
víctima a veces voluntariamente o de
creador porque pongo estas dos palabras
porque se relacionan estas dos palabras
quiero hablarles de mi experiencia como
artista
fácilmente los artistas entramos en un
juego en el que comenzamos a culpar al
medio a la falta de industria comenzamos
a culpar a que no tenemos apoyo de por
acá o que en ecuador por ejemplo la cosa
todavía no está tan desarrollada que ya
no hay disqueras etcétera etcétera
etcétera etcétera y esto inmediatamente
bloquea un proceso creativo y a veces
cuando un artista entra en este juego y
se sienta a crear una canción a mí me ha
pasado unas claves están amargado tan
resentido porque pasó aquello o esto o
esto otro que no permitió que esa
canción entre la lista de esta radio o
que nos lleve el premio de por acá que
el proceso creativo en ocasiones se
bloquea inmediatamente
pero no solamente nos pasa a los
artistas en medio de un proceso creativo
puede pasarnos a todos en cualquier
momento cuando tenemos que proponer
cuando tenemos que reinventar cuando
tenemos que replantear
en ocasiones la primera reacción que
salta es justamente la de la postura de
víctima pero definamos un poquito estas
dos posturas estos dos papeles de estos
dos lados de la moneda
y créanme que les hablo desde la
experiencia nada más que desde lo
experiencial
quiero compartir con ustedes esto que a
lo largo de los años ha sido una lucha
constante y sigue siendo una lucha
constante el escoger de qué lado me
tengo que poner
cada vez que tengo que enfrentar un
nuevo proyecto un nuevo disco una nueva
canción un nuevo escenario
cuál es mi materia prima así que quiero
hablar un poquito de esto y quiero que
vayan identificando si es posible cuánto
de cada lado les ha asaltado cuánto
tiempo se han quedado de este lado
cuánto tiempo se han quedado de este
otro lado porque hay unas
características que sin duda son
determinantes y siempre se presentan en
cada uno de estos de estas etiquetas por
así decirlo vamos a ver si lo roja
ok esto está funcionando
esta es una actitud bastante común y nos
encontramos esto en todos lados en el
trabajo entre compañeros de universidad
las características de la víctima pero
si ustedes se fijan hay una actitud
amenazante no es que la víctima
no me refiero a la víctima que se hace
de menos que se siente pobrecito no al
contrario hay unas características y
unas actitudes en el lado de víctima que
pueden configurar este tipo de actitud
me hizo por su culpa mira cómo me trata
no me deja es que no se puede es que no
tengo es que nadie me ayuda nadie me
considera etcétera etcétera etcétera
etcétera esto bloquea un proceso
creativo en cualquier momento
les hablo de la música
en un estudio grabación uno siempre se
está quejando créanme uno entre alestra
grabación y uno siempre está diciendo me
falta este preamplificador me hubiese
gustado grabar con una guitarra taylor y
capaz me hubiese gustado tener un
micrófono no hay más de ocho mil dólares
entonces mi disco no va a sonar bien y
por qué es que no tengo el capital para
montar nuestro de esa naturaleza y uno
puede construir una telaraña gigantesca
de responsabilidades delegadas y el
proceso creativo comienza a frustrarse
esta es una actitud que acompaña a la
víctima siempre
él me hizo él por su culpa nunca se
responsabiliza de su proceso en las
circunstancias en las que este proceso
parte o nace
una víctima por lo general cree que su
suerte se debe a su karma han escuchado
este tipo de frases por ejemplo en su
cruz es que eso me pasa a mí me pasa
siempre es mi karma hay una una
predeterminación voluntaria
a eso
a determinar una circunstancia en la que
me tocó estar ya nada así es esa es otra
actitud en el lado de la víctima que
también le resta potencia al proceso
creativo así que esto es algo que
revisar si ustedes van notando cosas de
este tipo créanme que no no es que nada
más aparecen cosas así porque somos
humanos hay hábitos adquiridos y hábitos
que en ocasiones sabotean nuestros
procesos creativos del lado que nos
encontremos en la vida en el caso mío
les hablo de ese lado de la música pero
créanme que el proceso creativo es muy
parecido en todos en todos los frentes
una víctima por lo general se enfada muy
seguido con todo y con todos porque no
se comportan como lo que él considera o
lo que él considera que es mejor otra
vez se presenta esta esta predisposición
a responsabilizar al resto de todo lo
que sucede
y claro esto esto acumula y la
frustración y termina en una actitud que
además se somatiza y se nota se nota a
leguas
tienen que hacerse las cosas les toca a
las víctimas hacer las cosas no es una
elección es algo que les llegó
y además culturalmente nosotros nos
enfrentamos con esto todo el tiempo
cómo estás sigue trabajando ya toca han
escuchado ese tipo de frases
y créanme estas actitudes están del lado
de la víctima y sabotean los procesos
creativos todo el tiempo
y luego además se repiten
comportamientos poco eficaces porque
normalmente hay una reacción hacia las
cosas desde la ira desde la frustración
no se capitaliza el proceso no se
revisan los pasos y entonces se repiten
comportamientos que son poco eficaces
finalmente los problemas nunca le
pertenecen siempre son de los demás y
esta es otra de las de las señales o de
los síntomas de estar en el lado de la
víctima y créanme que esto se hace un
hábito
alguien ha visto esto en su entorno
cercano
si lo han identificado lo han
identificado personalmente en ocasiones
porque uno salta a veces de un lado al
otro no este es un tema que más bien
digo yo hay que verse de forma
consciente y si uno identifica a estos
procesos en el comportamiento diario
modificarlos luchar contra ellos hasta
establecer patrones de conducta que nos
lleven a un lado creativo mucho más
poderoso
quiero también hablar de como la víctima
se convierte en un ser extremadamente
crítico en el juicio es lo primero que
se dispara
la comparación constante y la opinión
constante
para tratar de justificar y también de
aliviar un poco de su propia frustración
esto también es parte de esta actitud
y nos encontramos con esto a cada paso
aprende
si logramos profundizar y generar
conciencia de los momentos que disparan
este tipo de actitudes podríamos
enfrentar un poquito más esto desde lo
personal y les cuento a través de esto
desde mi propia experiencia el proceso
artístico quienes aparecemos con
canciones en escenarios inevitablemente
estamos comparando nuestros números hoy
por hoy la música se mide en números hoy
más que nunca cuantos views todo tu
vídeo cuantos likes tiene tu perfil
cuántos premios te ganaste cuántas
reproducciones cuánto cuánto cuánto y
cuánto y este hábito odioso en ocasiones
nos lleva a los artistas a este lado
pero con el tiempo me dado cuenta de que
pasa lo mismo en todos los entornos en
todos los aspectos de la vida y en casi
todos los trabajos
quiero pasar ahora si es que esto me
deja
al otro lado al lado del creador porque
también la parte del creador tiene sus
propias facetas sus propias
características quedó claro el tema de
la víctima desde lo que he tratado de
explicarles y compartir con ustedes
y es algo común creo que lo
identificamos todo el tiempo en el día a
día qué pasa con el creador
el creador se responsabiliza de aquello
que eligió para su vida es una elección
personal entonces me responsabilizo
efectuado el proceso que en ocasiones
presenta picos altos pero también
presenta picos bajos pero todo ese
proceso es mío me pertenece a mí porque
yo lo escogí yo decidí ser artista
decidió ser músico decidí ser el
compositor cantante y entiendo el lado
bueno y el lado malo por ejemplo el lado
malo que se sigue represando con
respecto a la percepción del lado
artístico es una idea que vas a vivir
han escuchado esto varias veces y esto
es parte de lo que nos sucede a nosotros
quienes escogemos este lado de la vida
la música y con mismos miedos y todos
altas y en ocasiones el proceso puede
llevarte a carencias muy importantes sin
duda es así pero es parte de mi decisión
y la acepto y la capitaliza porque
solamente de esa forma puede buscarle
una vuelta y ser creativo para que
precisamente esa realidad pueda cambiar
los creadores no buscan pretextos no hay
mucho que decir con respecto a esto
porque el creador siempre salta con una
solución
quien propone todo el tiempo es una
fuerza creativa constante quien no se
detiene ante los nodos ni ante los
problemas ni ante inconvenientes que
pueden ser permanentes que pueden ser
temporales siempre hay una respuesta
hacia la solución eso es creación eso es
un acto creativo todo el tiempo
y
en oposición a lo que mostramos hace un
rato nunca echa la culpa a los demás por
sus circunstancias personales
y esto es muy potente porque esto sin
duda reafirma la autoestima
esto se confirma lo que eres tu valía el
porqué de tus decisiones por qué
escogiste este camino o el otro
no echar la culpa a los demás por las
circunstancias personales es el punto de
partida más lindo que uno tiene para
empezar a crear porque uno acepta
inmediatamente la materia prima que
tiene alrededor esto es lo que hay con
esto voy a generar o voy a crear lo que
yo quiera por eso esto es tan importante
puede sonar un cliché pero créanme
cuando uno ve alrededor e identifica la
materia prima básica que uno tiene es el
primer punto de partida para realmente
proponer algo para reconfigurar esos
elementos elementos y crear algo nuevo
de eso se trata esta actitud
lo que habíamos dicho no se queja
propone y escoge hacer las cosas no le
toca aquí también hay una diferencia que
es determinante yo escojo hacer esto
escojo este camino escojo este modo de
vida lo disfruto pero también acepto el
otro lado porque cada camino tiene sus
recodos no me toca hacer nada escogí a
hacerlo y eso se ejerce día a día y
minuto a minuto que crean ustedes que
son capaces de decir que han escogido
todo lo que hacen cada día a cada
segundo
creo que es una buena pregunta porque
eso te permite reconfigurar áreas de tu
vida
en las que de pronto pierdes energía
escoger el camino y todo lo que
representa eso es parte de una actitud
creador
sus problemas le pertenecen
y digo hay que abrazar los problemas con
cariño con cariño tal cual son los
problemas son grandes maestros que
pertenecen llegaron a mí por procesos el
creador es dueño de sus propios
problemas y finalmente la visión
saludable de sí mismo y el respecto
personal llegan como como acto añadido
por todo este proceso
a través de estas dos descripciones
solamente he querido poner frente a
ustedes mi propia realidad mi propio
camino en ocasiones el lado de la
víctima que me ha llevado a
circunstancias muy difíciles de
enfrentar en términos de mi carrera
musical y como en momentos he logrado
saltar al lado de creador de a poquito
de a poquito hasta tratar de hacer un
hábito el quedarme en ese lado
y crear para mí como artista no
solamente es hacer una canción es una
actitud con respecto a todo el proceso
que involucra mi carrera como artista
y vuelvo a decirles estoy convencido de
que esto se aplica absolutamente en
todas las áreas de la vida entonces
finalmente
la característica más importante de un
creador
y esto ustedes lo conocen es que viven
el presente
creo que el acto creativo puro real nace
del presente uno por tomás recursos del
pasado sin duda pero cuando un creador
está
y siente su entorno y cuando me toca
hacer una canción logro trabajar con las
sensaciones que me llegan en ese momento
las cosas son verdades son reales pero
trabajar con eso exige apagar la cabeza
en ocasiones y entender el momento en el
que me estoy moviendo creo que la
característica principal del creador es
que vive en el presente
uno será el espejo en ocasiones y no
siempre dice si yo me quiero como soy y
esta también es una frase cliché porque
si uno se quiere realmente cómo es eso
quiere decir que uno ha hecho las paces
con todo su pasado
si a uno le preguntan qué cambiarías de
tu pasado y hay algo que queremos
cambiar quiere decir que hay un
pendiente con nosotros mismos pero si yo
me veo al espejo y digo si me acepto
como soy hoy quiere decir que hice las
paces con mi pasado porque si cambio
algo algún error o algún acierto el tipo
el que estoy viendo en el espejo sería
otro completamente sin duda
entonces vivir en el presente es la
característica principal creo yo del
creador
de quien asume la creatividad desde
donde sea
y quiero cerrar con esto porque quiero
cantar un poquito
fue un punto estamos
y quiero agradecerles por el tiempo por
escuchar un poquito de esto que han sido
capitalización de mis propios procesos
de mis propios quiebres
hablarles de lo que he hecho en la
música les podría hablar de algunas
cosas que logrados en la música pero
prefiero hablarles de lo que de lo que
no logré
de los momentos en los que me quebré
de los momentos en que en este día el
víctima
y de cuánto aprendí en ese lado de la
vida
esto que les acabo de decir
sencillamente ha sido capitalización de
esos momentos difíciles
y quiero regresar es muchísimo por su
tiempo así que les parece si cerramos
con una de las últimas canciones que
logre crear hace poco cuando la vida
y como en otras levanta las palmas
ayudaría muchísimo
creo que lo más valioso que tiene un ser
humano para entregar son palabras buenas
palabras
y a veces nos olvidamos del por favor de
la gracia se entienda la bondad de intro
de cast con la gente que más amamos por
alguna extraña razón lo hacemos fuera
con todo el mundo pero cuando llegamos a
casa nos olvidamos del buen trato y de
las buenas palabras me despido con esto
que se llama buenas palabras espero que
les guste
[Música]
todo lo que yo tengo en mi mente
por qué
claro
[Música]
y turismo
cuando todo lo que estoy
[Música]
si llegas
es una canción
[Música]
bailar
y
[Música]
muchísimas gracias cientos personas
[Aplausos]